first of all there is a convergence of
some very important trends one of those
is you know the huge youth bulge in the
developing world a lot of countries in
the world have a population that is
essentially predominantly youthful
beautiful book because the actual ad
side young but the elite too because the
young increasingly be handed over more
responsibility that it's a very
transformative waiting time what we call
chess development temporary innovations
are adopted and it tells you the way
that new ideas are spread within
societies and across borders at the same
time you see in the group of network
technologies which is very important you
know mobile phones web technology and
not in and even beyond the phone world
you know beyond the computer world you
are seen in the use of metrics sensors
and devices that are distributed devices
and how they all come together the rich
data that is so important because of the
kind of insight we can use that we could
never have ever ever encountered so
we're also talking about the world of
big data and how all these network
technology is the framework of big data
combined with a youthful population and
then moving beyond that a new kind of
politics of participatory politics in
which because youth are much more
inclined to understand your view and get
it over with and have the tools to do so
through network technologies mean a
completely new civilization of construct
is what I call it so we are towards the
edges of a new civilization new global
civilization another stream lee
extremely exciting